Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see how NVIDIA’s new
AI transfers real objects into a virtual world.
So, what is going on here?
Simple, in goes just one image, or a set of
images of an object.
And the result is that an AI really transfers
this real object into a virtual world almost
immediately.
Now that sounds like science fiction, how
is that even possible?
Well, with this earlier work, it was possible
to take a target geometry from somewhere,
and obtain a digital version of it by growing
it out of nothing.
This work reconstructed its geometry really
well.
But, geometry only.
This other work tried to reconstruct not just
the geometry, but everything.
For instance, the material models too.
Now, incredible as this work is, it is still
baby steps in this area.
As you see, both the geometry and the materials
are still quite coarse.
So, is that it then?
Is the transferring real objects into virtual
worlds dream dead?
It seems so.
Why?
Because we either have to throw out the materials
to get a high-quality result, or if we wish
to get everything, we have to be okay with
a coarse result.
But, I wonder, can this be improved somehow?
Well, let’s find out together.
And, here it is!
NVIDIA’s new work tries to take the best
of both worlds.
What does that mean?
Well, they promise to reconstruct absolutely
everything.
Geometry, materials, and even the lighting
setup, and all of this with high fidelity.
Well, that sounds absolutely amazing, but,
I will believe it when I see it!
Let’s see together.
Well, that’s not quite what we are looking
for, is it.
Yes, this isn’t great, but, this is just
the start.
Now, hold on to your papers and marvel at
how the AI improves this result over time.
Oh yes, this is getting better.
And, my goodness!
After just as little as two minutes, we already
have a usable model.
That is so cool!
I love it.
We go on a quick bathroom break and the AI
does all the hard work for us.
Absolutely amazing.
And, it gets even better!
Well, if we are okay with not a quick bathroom
break, but taking a nap, we get this just
an hour later.
And if that is at all possible, it gets even
better than that!
How is it possible?
Well, imagine that we have a bunch of photos
of a historical artifact, and, you know what’s
coming!
Of course, creating a virtual version of it,
and dropping it into a physics simulation
engine, where we can edit this material, or
embed it into a cloth simulation.
How cool is that?
And, I can’t believe it!
It still doesn’t stop there.
We can even change the lighting around it
and see what it would look like in all its
glory.
That is absolutely beautiful.
Loving it.
And, if we have a hot dog somewhere, and we
already created a virtual version of it, but
now, what do we do with it?
Of course, we engage in the favorite pastime
of the computer graphics researcher.
That is, throwing jelly boxes at it.
And, with this new technique, you can do that
too.
And, even better, we can take an already existing
solid object and reimagine it as if it were
made of jelly.
No problem at all.
And, you know what - it is final boss time.
Let’s not just reconstruct an object.
Why not throw an entire scene at the AI.
See if it buckles.
Can it deal with that?
Let’s see.
And…I cannot believe what I am seeing here.
It resembles the original reference scene
so well, even when animated, that it is almost
impossible to find any differences.
Have you found any?
I have to say I doubt that, because I have
swapped the labels.
Oh yes, this is not the reconstruction, this
is the real reconstruction.
This will be an absolutely incredible tool
in democratizing creating virtual worlds and
giving it into the hands of everyone.
Bravo NVIDIA.
So, what do you think?
Does this get your mind going?
What else could this be useful for?
What do you expect to happen a couple more
papers down the line?
Please let me know in the comments below.
I’d love to hear
your thoughts.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!